yeah welcome to this video a five minute
game here on icc and i'm playing great
master Simon Williams from the UK and
he's not playing his Dutch opening which
is a surprise his so the world leading
expert on the the classical Dutch the
also sometimes called a lien gang nevsky
variation instead we've got them a
benoni here surprisingly I didn't know
that he did you place this but ok it's a
blitz game you can try all kinds of
things and I'm going for this setup here
with the night g3 early h5 hmm very
quick age 5 yeah probably who should I
go pee should be too yeah let's let's
play this the h5 h4 wants to yes play
two dead time on my night and maybe try
to misplace a whites pieces but it's
also of course quite quite a weakening
weakening um- them yeah G for rg3 I
think G form in order to get the night
back to g3 yeah if you don't know a
william some is some very aggressive and
creative player is some also i'm done a
couple of chest DVDs on the dutch as i
mentioned he's an expert on this and
also on the french and you also wrote
books about the French and the Dutch
done again as mentioned very very
aggressive player which means them
here manages to score wins quite quite
often even against a very strong
opposition he beat a girl fund for
example last year and he also won
against polish number one rotters love
write a check also in his favorite Dutch
opening all right so enough talk and by
now I've got simply a winning position
he misplayed this terribly the questions
am i able to really win because he's
simply a very good at finding tactical
resources frm young he needs to play 93
already and g4s some then hanging I
think white has a pretty substantial
advantage already cannot play b5 also
I've prevented this bday five so he's
close to him being forced to give
material but it's still not totally easy
Bishop default not d3 check and this F
for movie can play I'm 93 and g4 then
hangs so it's not not one hundred
percent clear cut to this position okay
I think at the end I money to Castle
short I will never be able to Castle
long so let's let's go for this he's got
problems with playing at five because it
simply would open the G far from my
pieces not for his pieces okay so Queen
d2 I am probably getting Bishop g5 add
to the mix covering this the square I
mean means okay yeah here's some as
mentioned a very straightforward player
this opens up the the gphone the
question is some is it really a really
good for black
to do that the threatening f4 okay let's
kick this night now again a practical
games it's always always a bit tricky
the same position should be very good
for me but you can always get lost in
the complication and he's good he's good
at tactics as mentioned one point is
that his king is simply weaker than mine
but ok it's not it's not like like an
easy an easy win ok grab here I can I
can take a five if I want Queen deform
maybe take here yeah let's let's grab
this and play Queen d4 I think you need
so i thought he needs to tape with the
Queen this looks like no counter play at
all for black Queen d45 coming if I've
94 and and stuff he wants to go right
age five problem yeah but isn't this
just grateful bud let's grab here and
play e65 and rook rook takes Queen
e-form yeah we'll get a 5 Queenie form
just put some in a deadly pin I hope
yeah this is the last last kind of hope
to get something on the thing you cannot
believe that this should be winning f7 I
don't see I don't see any any kind of
threat simply everything's controlled
so now let's play Queenie for control
the g two square if everything else
fails that this is also covered and e7
next move is Gotti eight Cabot of course
ok so let's let's go here i am rook h4
how does the prevent this
ya don't see a move
yeah this is one age seven right age
seven and oh yeah and 294 check winning
the Queen yeah this was simply too bad
out of the opening cannot cannot play
this position think I'm around here a
couple of moves later it gets tricky
this H porn action here didn't really
help I mean white has a big big edge in
the center and finally after after after
this the Queen side is also dominated by
white after this it dips it's really
difficult to play play the position I
think I'm if you would give this to a
computer it would probably give give
white I'm almost winning advantage yeah
just one pawn maybe I could have played
it even more decisively yeah thanks for
watching hope you enjoyed the game